[Music]
what should we be doing
during this probationary period
well if jesus said as it was in the days
of noah and the days of law then it
behooves us to study the days of noah
and the days of lord so we can
understand how we need to live in these
last days we ought to so live as though
today is the last day that's how the
christian ought to live because it could
be the last day
you understand you can die tonight god
forbid or i and so we live as though
this is our final day on earth or our
final hour this calls for training of
the mind to live that way but we tend to
believe i'll be alive tomorrow that's
why we procrastinate i'll be alive next
week and we make these judgments about
how long we live no your life can end
today righteous people die every day
perfectly healthy people die god may
either take you or let you pass and so
we ought to live as though today today
if you hear his voice today is the
accepted time and this is the mindset
that the people of god should have and
constantly studying the word of god to
see how close the coming of christ is
because he said if we study the science
we realize that it's coming this close
even at the door so even though we have
no precise date you know august 28 2021
but he says even at the door and that's
very very close and so we live with a
sense of imminence christ is about to
come and we're constantly in the word of
god that we may more and more understand
the details of how we shall live our
lives in these very very troubling and
trying times and so a sense of urgency
and a sense of emergency must
characterize the daily lives of god's
spirit but unfortunately many of us are
so wrapped up in daily living we tend to
forget that there is something above and
beyond daily living and that is securing
your place in god's eternal kingdom when
he comes if you observe the lives in the
days of lot the bible says they didn't
eat they dried they bought they sold
they planted they built it and christ
says that's the way it will be you look
at those six things they bought they
they eat they dried they bought they
sold they planted they built it none of
those things is a sin they're all just
expressions of daily life but if you
just live a normal life life as usual is
poor preparation for the return of
christ let me say that again life as
usual is poor preparation for richard of
christ we must live life unusually that
is the way christ lived we must live
life unusually our priorities must be so
different our friends our colleagues our
associates begin to wonder well who are
you what's wrong with you but if we
believe we're in the last days and we
are we believe probation will soon close
and it will then we cannot live life as
usual there must be something else that
becomes the priority and that is a
preparation to receive christ when he
comes a preparation to live in a world
without a high priest in the most holy
place a preparation for the trials and
tribulations much more intense that are
coming up on this world a preparation
for the time when a death penalty will
be passed to take god's commandment
people out
that's how we should be living our lives
amen amen thank you for that explanation
on and one thing i would always say is
that just as we hear jesus is the author
and the finisher
you can also say that every day jesus
must be the author of our day and the
future of our day
yes this is a revelation each day so
make sure that you do not harden your
hearts as hebrews 3 verse is 15 tells us
you